they say that an aesthetic experience is
an altered state of consciousness like
literally this perceptual experience in
which you are shaken right in which you
are perhaps decentered actually
transforms the neural chemistry of the
brain
so if aesthetic experience is an altered
state of consciousness what are the
chief characteristics of this altered
state of bliss what does it take
perceptual II to experience a work or an
object of beauty what is going on what
is the neurology of that blissed-out
perception of an object of beauty I
particularly love aesthetic experiences
because they seem too archetypal eyes
the world they seem to turn any object
into something that stands for all of
its class a landscape looks like a
landscape painting right a work of art
hanging in the walls of the museum is
simultaneously separated from all
context it cans us come into the light
and be seen for the first time it forces
contemplation it forces a response and
perhaps it is this response that is the
aesthetic experience that we're after so
in a sense we're asking what are the
triggers what are the precursors that
can stage these cognitive
transformations we will pay money for
art what they're paying money for is a
particular state of consciousness this
is you could say that the consumption of
art is part of the altered States
economy as Jamie wheel and Steven
Collard
talked about and so it's a it's a
wonderful subject of inquiry I think for
any of us who enjoy the experience that
has been described by some as OPA today
Jason see where you're outside yourself
and beside yourself and essentially
becoming one with the aesthetic work
it's almost like the normal boundaries
between self and other dissipate and
there is this cosmic union with the
beloved object and man does that feel
good right that is artistic consummation
right with the Greeks called ecstasy's
and I think for this reason should seek
out to have more aesthetic experiences
in our lives and continues to demystify
this wondrous state of consciousness
known as aesthetic arrest
you